they want him back
Yaya Jame may be loaded by many Gambians
for his repressive 22 year long rule in
which human rights organizations believe
thousands were tortured and killed but
this crowd loves him calling him the
builder of bridges they're members of
Johnny's political party the Alliance
for patriotic reorientation and
construction also known as the a PRC he
can come as a private citizen and he
stands for election and he wins he can
come to president but knows and we want
him in fact to be a president of this
country we see what you've done to this
country and the entire Cold War
we've seen it he's a peaceful man three
years ago
Johnny said he would rule the Gambia for
a billion years he was forced out of
power into exile when West African
forces intervened when he refused to
concede defeat after losing the 2016
presidential election it is from the
comfort of his farm in Equatorial Guinea
that the 54 year old former president is
watching events unfold in his country
with many disappointed with current
president Adam ABARES leadership Johnny
supporters are nostalgic for the
stability that came with his regime and
so in a recorded phone conversation two
party leaders he says he wants to come
home John May believes he has an
agreement with the African Union and
West African leaders allowing him to
return to the Gambia while he may get a
hero's welcome from his party supporters
victims of torture and those that lost
loved ones at the hands of John Mays
security forces want to see him back in
the country as well but to face justice
Nicholas Hawke al-jazeera